OF THE YEAR BUT LOSE A HEART
BREAKER WEDNESDAY, TO THE
LAKERS, AND A GUT WRENCHING LOSS
TONIGHT AGAINST MEMPHIS.
LET'S GO TO RACHEL.
>> Rachel: HERE WITH JA MORANT.
YOU ARE IN THE NBA PLAYOFFS.
HOW DOES IT FEEL?
>> IT FEELS GOOD.
FIRST TIME, YOU KNOW, WE BATTLED
ALL SEASON.
HAD A CHANCE TO GO MY ROOKIE
SEASON.
JUST FELL SHORT A COUPLE GAMES,
LEARNED FROM IT AND NOW WE'RE
HERE.
>> Rachel: YOU HIT THE TWO
FLOATERSES IN THE END OF
OVERTIME.
HUGE PRESSURE ON BOTH SHOTS.
WHAT IS YOUR CONFIDENCE LEVEL
WHEN YOU'RE APPROACHING A BASKET
LIKE THAT?
>> THAT'S A SHOT I WANT TO TAKE.
I LIKE WHEN THE PRESSURE'S ON
ME.
AND JUST, YOU KNOW, UPLIFT MY
GAME.
YOU KNOW, I HAVE ALL THE
CONFIDENCE IN MY GAME, AND LATE,
YOU KNOW, COACH TRIED TO SET A
SCREEN.
I JUST TOLD HIM TO MOVE.
I WANT THE PRESSURE.
>> Rachel: YOU ARE 21 YEARS OLD.
YOU'RE TEAM OVERALL IS THE
YOUNGEST SQUAD TO MAKE THE
PLAYOFFS IN TEN YEARS.
LAST GUYS TO DO IT THAT AGE WERE
THE OKLAHOMA CITY THUNDER, WITH
KDW WESTBROOK W JAMES HARDEN.
HOW ARE YOU GUYS ABLE TO SHOW
SUCH POISE IN PRESSURE
SITUATIONS WHEN YOU PLAY TEAMS
SO MUCH MORE EXPERIENCED THAN
YOU?
>> WE JUST GO OUT AND BATTLE.
WE KNOW WE'RE A YOUNG TEAM.
WE HAVE SOME VETS THAT COACH US
UP AND LEAD US, AND ME BEING A
POINT GUARD, I HAVE TO BE A
LEADER.
OBVIOUSLY, YOU KNOW, IT'S MY
FIRST TIME MAKING THE PLAYOFFS
BUT WE HAVE SOME PLAYERS THAT
HAVE BEEN IN THE PLAYOFFS
BEFORE.
YOU KNOW THEY ARE GOING TO HELP
US OUT, AND WE ARE GOING TO GO
OUT AND PLAY OUR BASKETBALL AND
BATTLE.
ALL 48 MINUTES.
>> YOU SAID WHEN YOU LEFT TO
COME TO SAN FRANCISCO, YOU WERE
PACKING FOR A THREE-GAME ROAD
TRIP AND YOU ARE OFF TO PLAY THE
UTAH JAZZ.
BEST RECORD IN FACT THE LEAGUE
IN YEAR.
WHAT CAN WE EXPECT FROM THAT
SERIES?
>> MY FIGHT.
YOU KNOW, WE PLAYED THEM EARLIER
IN THE SEASON.
OBVIOUSLY, CAME UP SHORT.
I THINK TWICE.
I MEAN, THE BEST TEAM UNTIL THE
LEAGUE RIGHT NOW.
SO, WE KNOW WHAT TO